hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
I'm a property investor I've been buying
houses in the UK for over a decade now
can you believe it and one of the things
I get asked all the time is what it's
better interest-only payments when you
get a house you get a mortgage you're
gonna pay interest only or are you gonna
pay the mortgage back slowly and do
repayment I'm gonna be answering that in
this video however before you watch this
video if you watch my videos regularly
and you are not subscribed please do
that now it's amazing how many people
watch the videos but aren't subscribed
so subscribe to the channel smash that
like button and don't forget to hit the
notification bill so you never miss a
video so in this video I'm going to be
arguing for the position of
interest-only mortgages and the reason
I'm saying that is because that's what I
do I think that interest only is a lot
lot better than repayment 99% of the
time here's why most people in their
mind they think that debt is bad and
that's why they want to set up a payment
structure with their mortgage whereby
they pay their mortgage back over time I
don't think that is bad I think that bad
debt is really bad and good debt is
really good good debt is when you borrow
money like a mortgage and with that
money you vest in an investment property
and that property gives you money if you
take a mortgage and that mortgage its
facilitating cash flow into your life
and it's helping you be live and
financially free life then that mortgage
is your friends that good debt is very
good so why would you want to rush to
pay it off why would you not want to
actually go and get more of these good
mortgages and receive more cash flow the
only reason would be would be maybe fear
fear because you think well what happens
if the interest rates go up though I
just wanna be debt-free if you're
worried about the interest rates going
up then fix the interest rate you can
fix interest rates for up to 10 years
and you can fix it like 5% you can fix
it for two or three years at like 3% I
say like 3% like 5% because it depends
on your situation but that's very
standard in the in the practice listen
if you're borrowing money and you're
paying 5% even but you're making 20% as
a result then that mortgage
is serving you well most people want to
do repayments because in their minds
they want to be debt-free but rich
people are not debt-free rich people are
financially free meaning that they have
enough passive income and cash flow to
live life how they want and to not have
to look at the price tag of stuff it
means they don't have to work anymore
because their rents and their passive
income covers their lifestyle that's
what you want
not debt-free poor people want to be
debt-free because their parents and the
schools and the banks have said to them
the debt is bad when actually it's not
Robert Kiyosaki Donald Trump Grant
Cardone myself all wealthy investors
rely off of debt so as long as the
property's good you want to be getting
interest only now what happens at the
end of the term now you know what
happens in 35 years
when the bank wants their money back
well either at that point you're either
going to sell the property and what
happens to properties over time they go
up what happens to money over time it
shrinks what happens to your debt over
time your mortgage it shrinks because
money shrinks if your mortgage is fifty
thousand pound today and you've got
twenty thousand equity in there in
thirty five years time the equity will
be a lot more because the property's
gone up in value it'll be maybe 10 times
as much who knows the properties on
average double every 10 years so the
property goes up a lot which means
you're getting more and more equity I
would encourage you to pull that equity
out and buy more houses and then as they
as they go up buy more houses people
that want to pay repayment mortgages
people that think they want to pay the
mortgages off you know they want to live
live a life where they've got houses
where they've got no mortgages the
bottom line is all that money that
you're paying off the mortgage with is
going to take away from your cash flow
you would be paying 200 Panamint let's
say in just only but now you've decided
to pay 400 pound amount and to hundreds
go into the interest into engines going
back to the bank paying off your
mortgage but then that's gonna mean that
you're too in Japan short what you
should be doing is paying 200 and then
with the two in Japan hold that back
save it store it and reinvest it into
buy more houses if you truly believe
that houses are good investments if you
truly believe that we're on a small
island and there's an overpopulation of
people and a shortage of houses your
priority should be to just buy more
houses leverage other people's money
leverage the bank's money to buy as many
houses as you can because ultimately the
person who has the most property is
going to be the winner not the person
that has the least debt that's why I
believe in interest only at the end of
the term thirty five years
sell the house or refinance the house
and and pay the lender back and borrow
more money on the property because if
you've got houses you can usually leave
with your money against these houses the
goal is not to be debt-free the goal is
to be financially free don't come from a
position of fear your safety secure mind
will [ __ ] you because it's that same
mind that stops people doing anything
I'm not a financial adviser can't give
financial advice per se because that's
not I'm not able to do that but what I
am is I'm a very successful property
investor I'm young but I've been in the
game for 1112 years and I am a leverage
man I'm geared when I'm happily good
because I know that my houses are gonna
go up over time and if they don't it
doesn't matter because I'm making so
much money off of the rents and rents
aren't gonna go down rents are only
gonna go up that's my thoughts I'd love
to hear your thoughts I'm not saying I'm
right there are very tiny occasions when
sometimes I think some people maybe
should do repayment mortgages
specifically those people namely who
can't sleep at night if they've got
mortgage just because they're just that
that's the way they're wired I'm not
wired that way so I'd love to know your
thoughts please do comment below let me
know what your thoughts on interest-only
versus repayment also if you've got any
ideas for me to do video on anything
else any of the topics themes ideas
questions comment them in below I always
read every single comment when I can I
try and respond as well also as I said
before please do subscribe the more
subscribers I get the more content I'll
keep putting out please do subscribe and
I look forward to seeing you on the next
video peace out
[Music]